nous travaillons sous le signe de la
rigueur et n'attendez pas de moi des
facilités du genre deux américains un
pari il faut dire que la forte présence
d'hillary clinton on vient d'en parler à
beaucoup occupé les journalistes
aujourd'hui des clinton avait déjà eu
l'occasion de se promener dans la ville
lumière lorsqu'il était étudiant
cette fois le programme était d'eads -1
nettement moins touristique pour la
first lady suivis pas à pas par philippe
gassot et par michel tchanou latos
passage le plus tendre a sans doute été
la visite au musée rodin car c'est là
que des enfants d'une école voisine
l'attendait pourquoi mais bourdin j'ai
toujours aimé rodin et ses sculptures
plein de sentiments d'intelligence et de
force c'est cette combinaison qui me
fait tant dans son travail par les
français comme je le disais cet après
midi à une de mes amis c'est un de mes
grands regrets comme et français ne soit
pas meilleur qu'il met
à l'école de la rue du général camou
dans le viième on avait bien potassé
l'histoire de rodin
on avait aussi potassé quelques mots
d'anglais
après la surprise et le bonheur de
rencontrer la présidente des états unis
arrive jamais j'ai beaucoup de chance
moi je suis très ému parce que ça
m'arriverait qu'une seule fois ce matin
à visiter l'opéra et acheter des
chaussons de danse pour sa fille chelsea
rencontrer simone veil déjeuner à
matignon en compagnie du premier
ministre puis à l'assemblée nationale il
était 17 heures
elle a joué à la perfection les première
dame des etats-unis confidente et aussi
supporters